Let's look at the solution for what
happens in our directory MOESI quiz.
When Core 0 issues a read it
sends a request to the directory.
The directory doesn't forward or get any
responses, it just sends a response.
When there is a write, the Core 0
gets this block A in exclusive state
because MOESI has such a state.
Core 0 can do the right
without telling anybody.
So there is no request
sent to the directory, and
then there is no direct
activity as a result of that.
When Core 1 reads A,
it sends a request to the directory.
The directory will now
send a request to the only
core that is involved in sharing
this block, which is Core 0.
So it sends one message.
Core 0 responds with the data and
acknowledges that now it's
okay to read this block.
And when the directory gets this
message, it sends to Core 1 a response.
Now, Core 1 can read the block.
So now we have Core 1 has
the block in the shared state.
Core 0 is now in the own state,
because it downgraded itself
from modified to owned.
Core 2 now tries to read.
Sends the request to the directory.
The directory,
if it has only the state that we
have seen on the previous segments.
Does not know who is
the owner of this block, but
it doesn't need to send anything,
so it gets to memory.
The directory here doesn't
send any messages forwarded,
because it no longer sees
the block in the directory state.
So it doesn't forward anything,
it doesn't get responses,
it just sends a response back to Core 2.
Note that here we're unable to
benefit from the own state.
Simply because the directory doesn't
know to ask Core 0 to provide the data.
With a fancier directory,
we would be able do that.
But not with a directory that only
tracks presence and dirtiness.
So now C2 also has the block
in the shared state.
The same thing happens for
C3's request, there is a request,
the directory doesn't forward anything,
it just sends a response,
because it has to read the data from
memory, and now, Core 0 writes.
Because it's in the own state, it is not
able to write without notifying the
directory, so it notifies the directory.
This write is an invalidation
request because we have the data.
But we need to send invalidations
to these three processors, so
that the directory knows that Cores 1,
2, and 3, their caches have the block.
So it sends three messages
to these three destinations.
It gets three responses
from each of them.
Once they have all acknowledged
that they have invalidated,
it sends a response back to Core 0,
and now it's able to write.
So over all we had five requests
sent to the directory and
that also means that there are five
responses from the directory.
Because every request
will have a response.
The directory has
forwarded four messages.
Note that this is not like four out
of five, got messages forwarding.
In fact, one of these was for
one message and the other three were for
the second message.
And then we got four
responses to these messages.
Again, every message needs to get
a response because the directory cannot
acknowledge and allow a core to
write until all of the sharers have
indicated that they have invalidated
their state in the cache.